et
là il va bientôt y avoir autant de
constance que de mecs ça va être sympa
après l'émission comment ça va vous
connaissez
bon julia channel avec deux n pour
éviter confondent avec channel 1 est
pire qu'un semaine dont vous êtes une ex
star du porno
reconvertie dans le journalisme sur la
chaîne internet de michel field qui
s'appelle à la télé point com et puis
sur mcn la chaîne cap satellite
spécialisé dans la musique où vous avez
une émission de hip hop et de r'n'b 50
r'n'b la dette à ses copines avec les
rappeurs
naturellement est un peu l'égérie des
la mascotte d'ailleurs quand vous avez
votre hôte d'or ils étaient tous là bas
et nous resservent nous remettons ce
deuxième vote d'or d'honneur à julia
channel
je serai contente toi de tin oo je serai
contente que en fait cette soirée soit
placée sous le signe de la musique avec
des rats des groupes comme arsenic stomy
bugzy
doc gynéco
fassi tout le monde parce que maintenant
j'ai la chance de faire de la musique
entre autres avec stomy en 30 avec bambi
cruz avec plein de gens et je suis très
heureuse ce qui prouve qu'il ya une vie
après le x1 est ce que vous êtes là ou
pas
voilà sur la vie de moi et vous avez la
chance que je fais pas du x
les ardeurs et de la chance à la vie de
ma mère sinon vous aurez vu que je suis
le [ __ ] de chaud la porte du secteur
asie
ya mon pote pas si mon [ __ ] de les
grosses doc gynéco et l'ami jean la
chaîne elle fait du bruit pour son tour
d'honneur
je n'ai donc lors de la remise de son
hot d'or d'honneur avec tous ses copains
rappeur moi ils m'ont donné un 7 d'or
jamais donné l'autre dormait mais je
sais pas j'aimerais bien comme de nador
jour s'arranger
il va après tout avec tout les fidèles
énervé apparemment
donc alors à parler de vous geithner 73
votre pardon 3 3 novembre c'est bien
vous aider un autre portable est sorti
un jeu tout de suite votre terre et tôle
du mali oui vous connaissez le malibu
d'un spécialiste de l'afrique ici hein
ou bien cela
ça
c'est jean christophe rigaud
bien alors votre père a quitté le pays
après l'indépendance d'un artiste
peintre vous êtes la petite dernière
d'une famille de cinq enfants oui vous
avez commencé votre enfance dans le
xviiie au goût vous avez cinq frères et
soeurs donc comme vous c'était dans
combien de mètres carrés au début
c'était très petits c'était je sais pas
10 12 à peu près et puis après il ya eu
un peu plus d'argent donc on est parti
en seine-saint-denis dont 9 3 3 beaucoup
plus d'argent oui mais quand même un peu
plus et je les avais beaucoup d'argent
décernés dans de 7,8 cette richesse là
moi j'étais dans l'étude mais dans le
code du côté pas imposables au départ
vous êtes restés là bas de 12 ans un bon
espoir de 17 ans bah oui hein voilà
alors à la maison vous étiez super cool
super sympa parce que votre père était
un peu comme un louis j'ai eu une
éducation
plutôt militaire très très stricte très
très n'ont heureusement votre père vous
a donné l'implication un petit peu
stricte d'un petit peu militaire parce
que dès que vous étiez dehors vous
battiez vous voliez gtw j'étais une
enfant assez turbulente limite tourner
mal comme inscrits veillon ouais
j'aurais pu facilement passer
délinquante passe de l'autre côté ouais
voilà parce que je voulais beaucoup
j'étais une grande bagarre heureuse mais
je voulais bien c'est une bonne joueuse
pourquoi pas vous les vêtements je
rentre dans un magasin je mettais un
portal manque de portage ont donc
blouson le qatar ce tee shirt je serai
forte et je les revendais après normale
et et puis là ici aussi enfin ça c'est
beau ce but qu'elle raconte là
c'est pas ça non c'est les drogues dures
pour le divenach j'essaie tant besoin
d'un choc oui votre frère se suicide en
se jetant par la fenêtre
pourquoi parce que va citer quelqu'un
qui était un peu dans son c'était un une
sorte de poète musicien qui était bon
dans son monde et pas supporter ça le
monde réel je pense que voilà c'est ça
donc je vais complètement acceptés
voilà je mettrais bien pris surtout
c'est moi qui a appris la nouvelle en
premier donc c'est moi qui l'annoncent à
mes parents donc effectivement premier
choc quand on a 17 ans et et puis voilà
et puis en même temps ça m'a donné un
peu plus de force pour
rentrer dans la vie active
et surmonter ça oui le d'ailleurs bac
littéraire oui un fac d'italiens dont
trois mois trois mois oui mais le temps
de voir en même temps aquasure double
parce que c'est parce que j'avais envie
de faire et mais j'étais très bonne
taille et en bac j'ai eu 19 sur 20 donc
c'est normal
moi j'ai de bons amis italiens et suivez
moi parce que j'ai parlé beaucoup
d'italiens
une façon d'apprendre non mais c'est
vrai alors là vous commencez des petits
boulots un
petit studio petits boulots ou et puis
des photos pour arrondir vos fins de
mois et puis des photos de charme oui et
puis un jour il ya un agent de signer
porno qui vous propose un film vous
refusez vous dit non non mais je vais
pas faire ce boulot ouais vous quand
même temps vous mettez avant d'accepter
deux jours
où
on n'aurait pas ce que parce que je
voulais pas du tout faire ça en fait ton
temps c'est normal mais j'ai pris ma
décision
il faut pas se décider comme ça je vais
prendre deux jours et est donc en fait
ce qui m'a décidé c'est le cachet à
l'époque parce que comme j'étais
étudiante je faisais des petits boulots
genre serveuse et je finissais très tard
et je dormais trois heures par nuit j'ai
très peu d'argent premier fonds c'était
très peu d'autres encore pour faire part
de nos familles notre décembre des
échelles de temps mais combien d'âmes un
cachet du film et bas à l'époque c'était
un cachet qui était quand même
faramineux puisque c'était je sais pas
je crois une france qui est énorme qu'en
général ces 1500 francs j'étais dans le
double
alors vous en parler au départ ni à
votre famille à votre copain voiliers et
avec vos parents vous avez jamais parlé
ouvertement non on n'est jamais
on n'a jamais parlé et je crois que si
jamais jamais jusqu'à ce soir je n'ai
jamais parlé
n'en avait jamais parlé comment jamais
parce qu'ils ont eu l'intelligence de ne
pas m'en parler parce qu'il savait que
ça allait créer des conflits et voilà et
et en même temps ils ont été très
contents quand ils ont su que j'ai
arrêté parce qu'ils ont quand même suivi
ce qu'ils ont vu des magazines sont vos
missions et suivre votre père était
abonnée autre vidéo
nom et votre copain comme violées par
des je me suis pas un méchant dit paul
ouest avec lui après oui parce que je
lui ai dit écoute vos magies fait ça je
ne fais pas pour m'envoyer en l'air un
travail donc je les mêmes j'ai même
poussé le vice à l'emmener sur des
tournages c'est le cas de le dire voilà
pour qu'ils voient et je lui dis tu veux
rester de graisse et tu veux pas rester
tu te casses quoi et alexandre de voize
il savait non mais attendez il savait
que sa vie était une actrice du x et ça
ne dérangeait pas lui je pense que ça
l'a dérangé à un certain moment et la
danse vous devenez une star vous devenez
la perle noire du porno est une des
premières en france une des premières
noir ou vous n'êtes pas un oui à prata
omis kambale du porno d'une séance à 100
c'est vrai oui 120 films et c'est
l'époque ans et une grande époque
évidemment c'est l'époque de tabatha
cash que les sétois mata
de draghi que ça hein voila voila ma
béatrice van mais aujourd'hui vous êtes
un peu déçu par le milieu un vous dites
capus de ya plus de stars comme avant
c'est à dire que finalement même lors
sinclair vous dit pour être une star il
suffit pas d'être jolie d'écarter les
jambes dans le port louis exact ça je
pense que ça suffit pas parce que des
filles jolies en a beaucoup et si ça
suffisait toulon serait entre guillemets
star du x qui est un terme que j'aime
pas trop parce que pour moi il n'y a pas
vraiment de stars vont mieux mais ce qui
fait la différence dans ce milieu ce qui
fait que qu'une fille est plus reconnu
qu'une autre c'est son caractère qu'elle
marque une halle marque une génération
où pensez quoi par exemple des stèles
des enjeux rien rien et clara morgane
parce que c'est quand même la dernière à
rien vous êtes très sévère ah non non
mais quoi
moi j'ai travaillé d'une manière comme
hmm je n'en sais pas pas m'entraîner
sans merci pour pour vous pouvez le
faire
non mais rien parce que moi je sais que
j'ai travaillé longtemps est dur c'est
le cas de le dire et je crois que ça
suffit pas aujourd'hui de dire je tourne
avec mon mec uniquement avec mon mec
pour dire je suis une star mais voilà
ceci par clara
se débrouille pas trop mal comme elle
est mignonne n'ont éliminé alors bon
vous êtes une énorme star d'un seul coup
tout bascule évidemment il se passe des
trucs c'est une vraie vie un an 96 fait
un voyage au congo et en voyant des
petits enfants mourir du sida vous
prenez conscience du sida d'abord et
puis aussi du danger de faire ces films
porno sans préservatif quand vous
revenez voulait absolument que tout le
monde porte des préservatifs sauf que ça
se fait pas quoi non en fait ce qui
s'est passé quand sharon ce voyage qui
m'a vraiment traumatisés parce que
c'était du parti dix jours en tant que
reporter donc c'était déjà pas mon
métier et je suis allé dans les hôpitaux
voir les bébés qui est en train de
mourir qui sont orphelins qui va voir du
sida ça mapou donc j'ai sur place je me
suis dit il faut faire quelque chose
pour l'afrique parce que c'est un pays
qui me tient beaucoup à coeur et j'ai
réussi à rencontrer la femme du
président la femme de pascal lissouba
qui était président de l'époque et de
parler un peu avec elle des problèmes
là-bas et je voulais faire des quelque
chose pour eux je sais pas vraiment quoi
mais je voulais faire quelque chose et
c'est vrai quand je suis rentré je me
suis dit il est hors de question que je
tourne à zine de plus car voilà c'est la
prise de conscience je sent vibrer à 20
ans vainqueur dessous regarde
donc vous prenez votre retraite à 20 ans
génial cellules dans l'armée un nom tant
leurs armes ils apprennent à 40 ans et
vous renier pas votre ancien métier un
nom vous dit on vous entend jamais dire
de mal jallet alors évidemment la
question qu'on vous pose le plus
évidemment je vais vous la poser on va
bien sûr je suis maintenant je suis dit
oh je sais je sais je sais franchement
non rarement avec rocco siffredi camp
franchement non alors voilà
nommé rocco siffredi non
absolument pas parce que ce que j'ai
toujours expliqué c'est rocco c'est
quelqu'un c'est un grand professionnel
c'est la star the stars
un énorme sexe mais c'est pas moi
j'aimerais ça vous fait plaisir à
beaucoup de max
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de in a
l'habitude abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux